hello Sigma males and welcome back to
the channel so I am actually pretty
tired today and I don't really have any
energy to make up some new cringe 4chan
joke so as a result I am just gonna go
get right into the video I should
mention that I will be posting the
Banger of the century this Sunday so do
prepare yourselves to repost that to
Blind and watch it with an audience
anyways let's get into this thing we've
got to talk about consistent hashing
okay so I'm going to start off this
video by basically talking about
partitioning rebalancing and just kind
of one General schema that naively we
might use to partition some of our keys
so let's imagine we have got a bunch of
different Keys you know like Jordan
Karina
Kate
and we want to be able to go ahead and
Shard those to a bunch of different
nodes so naively you might do something
like this well what we would say is we
would take a hash of a key and since
we've got four partition nodes as shown
below we are going to take modulus of
four and then put it in the node
corresponding to that so let's imagine
the first key is 16 and then you know
that goes to node 0 16 divided by four
is you know take the modulus of that so
zero same thing with 28 and then we've
also got 12 and 19 also shown on the
screen but what if we were to change
things up a little bit because I were to
go ahead and nuke node three and so now
instead of being hash of key mod 4 we do
hash of key
mod 3.
so now all of a sudden where is 16 going
16 is going to Node 1 28 divided by 3
also actually going to go to Node 1 12
divided by 3 going to node 0 and then 19
mod 3 is also going to be going to node
1. so all of a sudden as you can see we
just had to move around a ton of our
keys and basically just move around a
ton of the data by using this modulus
function and so I guess the general
opening point of this video is if we are
trying to partition keys in a way that
is easy to kind of rebalance them when
we add new nodes or remove nodes from
the cluster we certainly should not be
doing this mod n partitioning right it
is not efficient because what that
results in is whenever the cluster
basically changes in size we have to
send the majority of our keys over the
network and that puts in unnecessary
strain on our system
so like we said modulus doesn't work
well then what does work what does work
is consistent hashing and that's what
we're going to be talking about in this
video along with one or two other quick
basically rebalancing schemes that we
can do so what's the point of consistent
hashing while consistent hashing is a
method of partitioning basically certain
values evenly amongst nodes in a way
that if the size of our cluster changes
a minimal amount of data is sent from
one node to the others so we'll see what
that looks like in a bit but you know
that's generally the point here which is
that we don't want to be doing too much
rebalancing if we can avoid it and not
only is this great for partitioning but
it's also great for load balancing load
balancing is a topic for another video
but the gist is sometimes we have many
application servers and we want to send
requests from our clients to different
application servers and so consistent
hashing is also useful for that again
the topic for another video
okay so let's actually go ahead and
demonstrate our algorithm so the first
thing we want to do is pick out some
value K and I'll explain the
significance of K later but right now
let's imagine k equals three so what
does k equal 3 here mean it means that
on this ring that I've demonstrated down
below for every single partition we're
going to pick three points we're going
to pick K points and so what the ring
represents is basically our hash range
remember hash range partitioning
which is basically taking uh the hash of
each key and then sharding it to a node
corresponding with a range of that
hashing
so as you can see Zero is at the top of
the Ring 250 is the right side 500 at
the bottom 750 on the left it's
effectively a clock and so for every
single one of our partitions as you can
see we've got partitions one through
four we're gonna pick three points on
this ring so now let's answer a couple
of questions let's say I'm talking about
node three what keys actually belong in
node three to figure that out we look at
our ring and we say okay well I see a
node 3 point right here and that is
going to contain all of these Keys along
this part of the circle so for the sake
of this video Let's imagine that's like
zero to a hundred
so those are going to be in node three
but similarly we've also got a point
over here
which is also on node three and so this
range of keys is going to be in node
three so that's going to be let's say
200 to 250.
and then also node 3 is going to be here
as well and so that is going to be let's
say I don't know 700 to 800. and so
that's actually going to be the range of
hashes of keys that are going to be
contained on partition three
and so you see the reason that we can
kind of generalize this out is that for
every single one of these nodes all you
have to do is go clockwise until the
next node Point comes up and you know
that range of keys is valid so again you
know like for node one for example this
range of keys will be on node one and
you know so will two others okay so now
the point here is y is consistent
hashing so useful what's so good about
it well I said the entire point is not
only does it distribute things evenly
but also it is going to basically
minimize the amount of things that we
have to send over the network when a
node is added and deleted okay so let's
start with say deleting a node I'm going
to first start by deleting node four so
I'm going to get rid of this oh god I've
really messed up now haven't I let me
get rid of this here let me get rid of
that there get rid of this here get rid
of that there
and get rid of this here so as you can
see there were a bunch of things that
were on node 4 right they were over here
and over here but now those are just
going to be extended into node one
they're going to be extended into node
three they're going to be extended into
node 3 again and you'll see that even
though node 4 was actually removed here
we're not rebalancing any of the data on
the other nodes that were not touched
we're just taking node Force data and
distributing it in a relatively even
manner amongst our other nodes let's now
go ahead and say I added node 4 back so
we're going to add node 4 back in a
bunch of random places
let's say I added here and remember we
have to pick three points I added back
here and then I will add it over here so
now instead of basically requiring all
of the keys to shift around again we're
only forcing a small portion of the keys
to actually be shifted to node four so
now node four is gonna in this case it's
gonna steal these or rather it's going
to steal these Keys over here from node
one it's also going to basically steal
these Keys over here from node two and
then finally it's going to steal these
Keys over here from node two so by using
this consistent hashing ring we can
ensure that we're not over rebalancing
like we were in the first example recall
that in the first example we were taking
keys on nodes that weren't even really
being touched and we were sending them
all over the place there's no reason to
have to do that if we can avoid it and
that is what consistent hashing is
accomplishing for us
so another method or basically an
analysis of consistent hashing is that
the way we can think of each node is
actually having a fixed number of
partitions so in this case the fixed
number of partitions was actually going
to be that variable k
so we've got K over here we set it to 3
and K is basically the number of
partitions per node so there are
actually some mathematical guarantees
about consistent hashing in terms of the
distribution of the keys you're welcome
to look them up on Wikipedia frankly I
don't think it's really that important
for the sake of this video but it is
cool if it's something you're interested
in Okay so we've discussed now the
concept of having a fixed number of
partitions
per node
but another possible partition
rebalancing method that you'll often see
is actually just doing a total fixed
number of partitions and that's not per
node but it's per system right so like
our entire back end has a total fixed
number of partitions so let's imagine in
this case that we have 12 partitions
here's what it would look like if we
lose a node
basically what's going to happen here is
you know originally all of these guys
start out with four partitions and then
once uh our third node is deleted we can
take a and b
and send it to the first guy and take c
and d and send it to the second guy
similarly another option is that you
know if we gain a node because all of a
sudden we want more partitions we have a
lot of data we can actually take you
know a and b and c and d and you know
basically distribute them out evenly so
I drew this out wrong but the point is
as you can see from our fourth node over
here it's going to take the d partition
from all three of these guys so we're
going to borrow this we're going to
borrow this we're going to borrow this
and that's what happens when we gain a
node so basically using a fixed number
of partitions is very viable in the
sense that it's simplistic to think
about right we know at all times how
many partitions there are total and so
we can easily assign them from node to
node however it also does come at a
downside which is that we actually have
to choose a pretty good number so what
happens if there are too few partitions
well let's say we have I don't know 10
partitions in our system but we also
have an exabyte of data well that means
that every single partition is going to
be an exabyte divided by 10 so I guess
100 petabytes and you can't fit 100
petabytes of data on one hard drive so
you're basically just taking an L there
if you only choose 10. at the same time
if you were to do too many
basically now we have a bunch of
overhead on our hard drives of you know
keeping track of what partition means
what so for example you know I have to
keep track here that partition one is
corresponding to the range 0 to 72
here's the same thing with Partition two
all the way through partition n so if we
have a bunch of those you know this
table could in theory take up some extra
space on our disk and we don't really
want to be doing that
okay so the last thing I'm going to
touch upon in this video is the concept
of dynamic partitioning so even though
all of these partitioning schemas allow
us to rebalance our nodes it doesn't
necessarily mean that that's going to be
happening on its own oftentimes there's
probably going to be some sort of data
center kind of Representative or you
know person who's really trained in this
making sure that load is getting
balanced properly and if not making the
proper adjustments that being said it is
possible that the database could
actually manage its own rebalancing
however this does run a risk which is
that if you do it too often as in you
know let's say you rebalance when you
don't necessarily need to the nodes are
just fine but you know maybe you
accidentally think one is down well then
all of a sudden we start sending a bunch
of rows of our data over the network we
don't need to and we're actually putting
a greater cost on our system in order to
do that and so I guess the question then
kind of becomes well how do we even know
when our system is down how can we agree
upon this type of thing and of course
what do we we do about it well
it's not so easy to know when a system
is down and frankly this type of video
begs many many others and of course
that's what we'll be doing next so look
forward to distributed consensus guys
because that's what's next on our plate
anyways have a great night everyone I am
going to pass out and uh yeah enjoy
yourselves